People have questions about metastatic cancer. So they think and I know you guys probably aren't anybody listening to this. Probably already done with this, but it just seems so common out there in the world.
About about people thinking that since their cancer has metastasized that it's a different cancer.
So I get this common on case review calls and people initially call in and say, at breast cancer, it's metastasized to bone.
So how would you program a knife machine, you have to put in bone cancer? And of course the answer is no, because when a cancer metastasizes, it's still the same cancer.
So let's say if I am prostate cancer metastasizes to the bone, it's prostate cancer cells in that bone.
So if I was going to have a biopsy of that bone to make sure that it is cancer that's destroying the bone, they would see prostate cancer cells. That's why they would know that it's metastasis of that prostate cancer to the bone.
The definition of metastasis is that cancer is moved from its primary site to another site. That's what the metastasis is. It is still that answer.
Now it is true that a person could have more than one type of cancer at a given point. I have a number of patients right now. I think I have five people right now as patients that have two completely different cancers.
So they have two primary cancers.
So they might have a, you know, let's say they have an ovarian cancer and they have a lung cancer. Now ovarian cancer can spread to the lung.
But if it is true, a person could have two different primary cancers. And if that is the case, then we would have to program the right for both of those cancers.
Now, would you have to change the program on a right if I knew I had metastasis. I've gotten this from patients, you know, a number of years ago, you know, I had breast cancer.
Now I just wanted to metastasize to ID to change the right program. And the answer is no because it's still it's still breast cancer cells in the bone.
Now, is there a time that you wouldn't want to update the frequencies of your life for other reasons? Yes, there may be.
So let's say I have, you know, breast cancer and it's and it's pretty stabilized and I'm really having a lot of issues with my God, and I did a
at GI stool test and it's positive for H. Pylori. Could you decrease the amount of cancer frequencies in a given night and put more H. Pylori frequencies because I don't have time to run H. Pylori during the day.
That's a good question and that's a good reason to update a person's cancer program.
So, I feel very comfortable doing that. If a person's cancer was still very active and their cancer was growing still, I'm saying we're just hopefully just starting to put the break some of the cancers in a growth phase.
But they're having a lot of gut issues and they want to add H. Pylori wouldn't feel comfortable about doing that because you need to be running as much cancer program as possible.
So that's really important. So don't you don't want to take away from your cancer frequencies to deal with comorbidities unless your cancer is in a state of, you know, relative remission.
So, but understand metastatic cancers are the same cancer that's just moved to a different organ or the goal or whatever.
So it isn't the different cancer.
It's the fastest to the world. It's not bold cancer. It's still prostate cancer in the bone or whatever that primary cancer is.